with high standards today you're not
going to get elected the only way to get
elected today is with low standards with
today's policies to to inject the
concept of high standards i believe into
men and women of a nation
[Music]
you need the support of education you
need the support of universities you
need the support of you need you need
the support of a lot of people to get it
to say you're right the way we can
resurrect what we once had we all need
to buy into high standards low excuses
responsibility reliability pride in our
nation pride in our last name pride in
the fact that i'm i'm an immigrant i
came from iran and even though i'm made
in you know i'm born in iran i'm made in
america i got pride for my blood but i
love the country that gave me this
freedom that message today resonates
with a percentage the other percentage
sister and say
you're arrogant i can't believe you're
saying this again this doesn't mean feel
sorry for me this message is not going
to sell this just mean say it anyways
don't be afraid if you're losing certain
people